io sono qui per raccontarvi esperienza
dell'as causa banda che un'esperienza
bellissima basata sulla passione
sull'emozione sul sull'energia di alcune
anime un po visionarie di questa città
innanzitutto mi presento io sono
antonella riccardo appunto sono
innanzitutto una mamma sono una
ricercatrice in fisica è solo una
musicista per passione
in realtà questa passione è
sopravvissuta fortunatamente alle
angherie della mia insegnante di
pianoforte per avuto un insegnante
rigidissima la quale riteneva che
fondamentalmente il divertimento non
fosse assolutamente contemplato nella
formazione musicale
quindi o la odiata profondamente e
quindi il giorno del mio diploma di
pianoforte mi sono praticamente sentita
liberata è stata veramente un giorno di
liberazione per me ho chiuso a chiave il
pianoforte non l'ho toccato per anni e
ad un certo punto però fortunato mento
iniziato anche a toccare altri strumenti
e con questi strumenti ho scoperto che
la cosa più bella di far musica e far
musica insieme agli altri per
raccontarvi della scala banda devo dirvi
anche qualcosa sul quartiere nel quale
viviamo
io vivo a montesanto che un quartiere
molto popolare molto complesso
all'interno di una città evidentemente
complessa come napoli
all'interno di questo quartiere che è
estremamente eterogenea come
composizione sociale vivono molte
famiglie di immigrati molte famiglie che
vivono in condizioni di disagio
economico di degrado sociale molte
famiglie come la mia come la vostra
probabilmente queste varie anime in
realtà convivono all'interno dello
stesso spazio fisico occupa lo stesso
spazio percorrono le stesse strade tutte
le mattine ma di fatto non interagiscono
per nulla sono come dei mondi paralleli
che si muovono insieme senza nessun
mescolamento d'altro canto c'è da dire
che montesanto proprio forse per questa
ragione ha anche una vocazione naturale
all'attivismo all'associazionismo ed
infatti la scalza banda nasce
all'interno di una rete che la rete
delle scalze che ha sede in una
meravigliosa chiesa barocca di cosimo
fanzago appunto nel centro del quartiere
e pene che anche il nome da da quello
ovviamente quindi diciamo che la scarsa
balenata fondamentalmente da una mistura
di motivazioni personali e motivazioni
anche legate al contesto cioè da un lato
c'era l'idea di costruire attraverso la
musica un percorso di integrazione
favorire un percorso di contaminazione
di comunicazione intesa nel senso
proprio di relazione emotiva i bambini
provenienti da contesti così diversi
vivono insieme questa esperienza forte
medi crescita fortemente aggregante e
questo percorso li famo da un lato si
affianca poi all'altro obiettivo che era
quello di poter consentire
ai bambini di avere un approccio alla
musica divertente io appunto sono mamma
e dal momento in cui sono diventata
mamma o fortemente desiderato che la
musica forse parte della vita delle mie
figlie ma che ci si potessero avvicinare
col sorriso in maniera gioiosa in
maniera divertente quindi da questi in
serie di motivazioni è nata la scarsa
banda quattro anni fa con pochissime
risorse ovviamente con tantissimo
entusiasmo con mille difficoltà e con
una ventina di bambini
dopo quattro anni adesso il nostro
progetto ha sempre come dire le stesse
poche risorse però ha triplicato
sicuramente il numero dei bambini e
quello dell'entusiasmo non c'è il numero
che lo descriva adesso la scarsa domanda
coinvolge 75 bambini non li vedrete
tutti però ne vedete un certo numero
come capite bene dal numero di serie e
coinvolge anche 40 tutti principianti
perché ad un certo punto abbiamo pensato
che poteva essere bello avere una banda
veramente multi generazionale come le
bande di paese proprio caratteristica di
via delle bande di paese quindi gli
adulti si uniscono ai bambini e spesso
costituiscono insieme questa banda
enorme di 120 elementi che vanno dai 5
75 anni e non solo gli adulti in questo
modo anche danno un sostegno di tipo
economico al progetto per cui è una
forma di auto sostegno di chumby auto
sostenibilità del progetto stesso
l'esperienza diciamo ha prodotto esiti
assolutamente superiore alle nostre
aspettative nel senso che i bambini non
solo si vivono insieme l'esperienza
della banda ma si riconoscono anche al
di fuori della banda i bambini
cominciano a condividere spazi luoghi
anche diversi appunto da quello della
banda che comunque è stato il veicolo
per il superamento di certe barriere
appunto sociali e culturali
io in realtà non aggiungere molto altro
se non una nota sulla fatica ovviamente
è un progetto estremamente faticoso
estremamente richiede molto tempo molte
energie le mie bambine dicono con una
nota a metà tra insomma il divertito e
il non divertito che in realtà mamma ha
tre figlie e gioia mela scalda bamba in
qualche modo effettivamente hanno in
parte ragione
spesso appunto la gestione delle prove
d'insieme con così tanti bambini e
faticosa io mi sono meritatamente
come dire conquistata il titolo di
signorina rottermeier perché delle volte
sono costiamo costretti a contenere
diciamo la vivacità dei bambini e quindi
lo spettro della mia insegnante si
rimpossessa di me però va bene va bene
così perché in fondo
come dire la le emozioni che questi
bambini ci regalano sono enormi e questo
consente abbondantemente di ripagare me
e tutti coloro che con infinita
generosità si prodigano in questo
progetto di tutto il lavoro fatto quindi
sono sicure emozioni hanno moltissimo
anche voi quindi la scaldabagno